we grow up with these things i call
invisible scripts and these are the
scripts that are beliefs that are so
powerful
we don't even realize that they're
they're around us that's why they're
invisible so a classic one in america is
the american dream
is
buying a house
where did that come from and in fact
there's all these phrases that people
use like
you're throwing money away on rent they
don't make more land you know and on and
on
if you really deconstruct that and you
actually run the numbers you might
discover that actually buying a house is
often not the best investment and this
is super counterintuitive people get
really mad because real estate is
religion in america but if you actually
dive in deep you might discover wow
there's a lot of parties who want me to
spend a ton of money that's why for
example i could buy today but i rent and
when people hear it they're like wait i
thought i will teach you to be rich guys
rich so why is he renting they get very
confused because real estate is religion
you know another thing that is um really
common today for people is there's no
way to get ahead right especially for
young people social security won't be
around et cetera et cetera
and i just don't believe in that i think
if you go on to reddit or you go on to
these places where it's a it's a lot of
people who are
disaffected young people they create an
echo chamber of other people who want to
victimize themselves
then you have a choice do you want to be
reading those threads or like i was
reading the comments on your youtube
videos i was like these are the best
youtube comments i've ever seen people
are positive constructive they're
pointing out things they saw in the 32nd
minute of the video meaning they
actually watch the whole thing
those are the kind of people that i want
people to be around so it's not
impossible to make money there's
actually a lot of people making money
it's not impossible to get ahead pay off
debt even invest and grow there's a lot
of people doing it but if you're
surrounded by people who constantly
complain about how difficult it is and
it's impossible guess what you're going
to absorb those invisible scripts i had
a woman who wrote me and she said ramit
can you help me convince my husband not
to waste money
and i go okay what what's going on she
goes he spends so much money on iced tea
and i was like here we go
i go how much money and she goes he buys
iced tea 20 times a month like almost
every day i said how much is this iced
tea she said it's a dollar fifty each
time so in my head i'm like this is
insane like why are we even talking
about this but i knew there's something
here so i want to unpack it i said out
of curiosity what's your household
income
no response for 20 minutes okay and then
finally she comes back she goes i'm not
comfortable sharing that
i said just give me a range okay what do
you think her her and her husband's
household income is i know the story i
i would have guessed otherwise
80 000
like a nice
600 000
and the this is a perfect example like
rationally and logically we should
literally not be talking about this
because it's a rounding error but
there's something going on in her belief
system
that made her
fixate on iced tea
and so for anybody whether it's iced tea
or whether it's you know lattes is a
classic example everybody tells you not
to spend money i'm like that's the worst
advice ever buy as many lattes as you
want or some people they just love
for example clothes right i like clothes
they love it
but everybody around them has told them
things like that's shallow that's a
waste of money you should invest in your
roth ira and so what do they do all of
us we're torn apart because we live in a
paradoxical society that is both
puritanical telling us we should retreat
into a cave and do nothing but then we
go on instagram and everyone's in bora
bora where it's ridiculous and so what
do we do
we just buy everything and then we feel
guilty it's the worst
possible response so what i do is first
i say
what do you love spending money love and
nobody talks about this they always say
oh let me see your budget you're
overspinning and everyone's just like ah
forget this
i'll never come on here and berate
someone for their spending because i've
seen it all
when they talk about what they love then
i say what would it feel like to be able
to spend two times or four times as much
on that people have never thought like
that
then once we start from a place of
aspiration of what do we want
let's work through the mechanics of how
to get there really fast define a rich
life for people because i think that's
going to be a key component to this
whole discussion well it's different for
everyone my rich life early on was to be
able to go to a restaurant and order
appetizers because i never did it when i
was a kid like ever we would go and we'd
eat out once every four to six weeks if
we had a coupon and we would like share
two cokes with the whole family and we
would never order appetizers so i was
like i'm gonna do it and then the next
dream for me was to be able to
hop in a taxi if i lived in new york
during the summer without having to take
the train and sweat before a meeting
now my dreams got bigger and there's a
variety of things that are my rich life
but everybody's is different so some
people i have people in my book they're
like i use your book my wife and i
retired at 35 and 36 we drive around in
an rv
i don't want to drive around in an rv
but he and his wife do and i love that
so a rich life is what you define and
when i ask people what's a rich life to
you they usually say two things freedom
which is a very nice word but it's kind
of generic and they say a number usually
a million bucks and i say like freedom
what is what is that to you and they're
like i want to do whatever i want when i
want
and i'm like
get specific you want to order
appetizers do you want to do yoga at 3
p.m and that's where the conversation
stops so if you're watching i want
everyone to think what is your rich life
and take it from the clouds to the
street i want to buy three different
lululemon tank tops a month because i
don't ever want to have to wear an old
one whatever
go as crazy as you want
i want to travel for a month and i want
to bring my family with me
great a rich life is different for
everyone but is about your definition
most of what you see with money
is just this
mathematical logical stuff and it sounds
good and everyone's like oh yeah
compound interest but then they go back
to their day-to-day life which is like i
want that sweater i know i should be
doing this how come i'm not doing that i
feel bad
close the book forget it
and i want to take a really different
approach a perfect example is if you
look at any money book anybody watching
go look at any money book look at
chapter one you know what they tell you
to do in chapter one of any book
fine let's find out how much you spent
last month and people are like no thanks
see you later they don't know how much
they spent but they know it was bad
right and so if you actually understand
human psychology
you know that
my goal is not to make you feel bad my
goal is actually to show you how money
can be positive how you can live a rich
life whatever you want so in chapter one
of my book i said look we all use credit
cards we all suck at using credit cards
and we all hate credit cards let me show
you how to beat them read these words
off the page this battle tested script
and you'll get your fees refunded and
you'll get all these perks you don't
even know about people did they're like
i don't know this indian guy is kind of
weird i'll try it
they pick up the phone even millennials
who are afraid of using the phone they
picked up the phone they did it and
they're like oh
they're talking they call the bank they
call them
yes
and
like that they get a 35 fee refunded or
they get some perk they never even knew
existed and suddenly
psychologically they go oh my god
i can take control of my money it's not
all these huge concepts of retirement
inheritance and all this stuff no
i called i got money back
now i can do it
so it's so important to be to be really
incorporating your own psychology when
you think about money and part of that
is what do i want where did i get these
beliefs from whether it's a movie or a
family friend and then what can i do
today to start moving along and
developing my rich life wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carl michael and this channel
is created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to start
multiplying your money
enjoy
[Music]
rule number two get cash flow with grant
cardone by the way you should emulate
success
when investing and what is the warren
the oracle probably the greatest
investor of all time says number one
never don't
lose money the dlm the old down low
money number two the old man said get
you some cash flow
i think a lot of you misunderstand that
warren said invest for cash flow
he didn't say your second flow should be
investing
and i'd had this conversation with him
if i had dinner with him
and number three if i could afford to
have dinner with him
i can't afford to have dinner with him
because as soon as i'd get there i'd be
like this is going to end and that would
cause me a lot of problems
okay number three what do we say here
never depend no long term
long term you got to be in this deal for
a long term this is what led me these
three rules by the old man warren
buffett is what led me to investing in
real estate so every monday i come to
you to advise you your family wherever
you are whether you're making you got a
job right now you're making 60 70 000
bucks a year or maybe you're making 600
grand a year or six million dollars a
year and you're like how do i get out of
this thing that i'm in
and start creating other flows for
myself okay number one don't lose money
number two cash flow number three
long-term be a long-term investor when i
buy a piece of property
for
four million dollars
okay
i just want to test these three criteria
captain ryan's with us real estate ryan
good to be here and i put one million
dollars down
how can i possibly lose my 1 million
dollars
okay i financed 3 million
by the way the old man would like me
financing this deal long term 10 years
10 years of debt on this from a good
bank that believes in my property that's
actually a partner with me
okay i'm using the bank like i would
warren buffett's money as a partner so
when i put when i buy a four million
dollar real asset
that produces cash flow and i put one
million dollars down what has to happen
ladies and gentlemen my friends on the
instagram to youtube to facebook and the
itunes that are listening to me because
you like stevie wonder you can't see
how do i lose my money you tell me how i
lose my money i'm buying in miami
orlando tampa houston texas a lot of job
growth i know the market that i'm
i know the market that i'm buying in
okay i have tenants in the building
how do i lose my one million dollars
because that's what we're talking about
here how would i lose one million
dollars one two if it provides cash flow
every month four percent five percent
six percent eight 8 10
if it provides me with annual cash flow
every month i get a check
even if the market goes down and i don't
have to sell
if i'm in it for number three the long
term i should make money in the future
it's just when when do i make money so
that's what led me i started studying
because i love real estate i'm like i
need to buy real estate the cash flows
not
real estate
what real estate is going to cash flow
today next month
next year
and 10 years from now apartments
what do you think
since
1945 the rents in america have gone up
since world war ii look at how many
recessions we've had between 1945 and
2017
at 70 years
and rents did this the whole time
it's a graph
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding you don't stop
you don't stop 50 you're trends
you don't stop 50-year trends okay so
it leads me down to what apartments
right
gives me apartments and he leaves me at
mobile homes leaves me in storage i need
to focus on one of these because i'm a
focused person i'm not going to try to
do everything
so i started looking at apartments can i
understand apartments first thing i ever
bought was a single-family home i put a
renter in it if you know my story i put
a runner in it renter moved out i was
like oh that doesn't work sold it got
rid of it i said i'll never do that
again what did i do wrong
one door one door okay if you're taking
notes and you want to go do this
yourself i'll help you do it yourself by
the way you don't have to invest with me
okay never buy one door ever
you want to buy lots of doors the more
doors the better the more the the number
of units the most important number in
real estate the single most important
number and brandon will talk to you
about this tomorrow in any business
the most important number
is the number of in this case units
in a business it would be volume it
would be it would be it could be square
footage it's going to be huh
it would be how many times can you
multiply that unit times
and the bigger you can get that number
that's why netflix works facebook works
amazon works because these people are
trying to scale that rule number three
become financially literate with robert
kiyosaki i always ask people
what did you learn about money in school
and for the answer for most people is
nothing they want to learn economics
balance a checkbook but that's really
not
money
and the reason they don't learn about
money is because the story of rich dad
poor dad
is my poor dad it was a phd which stands
for poor helpless and desperate
no it's a good man but as you know they
don't learn much about money and my
father knew nothing about money
and that's the problem so we have all
these academic elites you know like
obama and hillary and those guys
they run the country with no financial
education
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four aim to become an
owner with david bach on the game of
monopoly
you go past going to get a paycheck and
if you just go around the properties
and you land on them you pay rent right
and you can't win the game monopoly
unless you buy one green home then two
green homes and three green homes and
four then a hotel right like you have to
be an owner in the game of monopoly the
ironic thing is that the game monopoly
is a great lesson for all of us for life
you have to own assets that make you
money while you sleep that grow while
you sleep
and
the challenge for most of america is
that this stuff is not taught in school
my grandmother when she started at 30
she had nothing and she used to
literally save 50 cents a week and put
it in a coffee camp wow and at the end
of the year she took that coffee count
down into a brokerage firm and start
investing in stocks that's what changed
the entire destiny of my family wow was
that my grandma 30 with no college
education
working at gimble's department store
milwaukee wisconsin
got tired
of being poor
there's some people watching today that
are there right they're listening
they're watching this or they're
listening to this and they're tired of
being poor my grandmother was frustrated
and she came home and said to my
grandfather on her 30th birthday
jack
this is not working
like and when you're the guy and you
hear that you're like what do you mean
this isn't working and my grandfather
said what's not working and she said
we're broke
we have any money
and you know to my grandmother's credit
she decided to do something about it and
so she literally brown bagged her lunch
every day she brown bagged her lunch so
she could save that money and go invest
and the way the story turns out luis is
my grandma thought my first book smart
women finished rich was dedicated to her
she didn't become rich overnight
she built wealth over her lifetime yeah
i always say it's decades not days
people who try to get rich quick stay
broke long
it's true
like show me those banner ads on how to
get rich quick and i'll show you a way
to stay poor forever right so my
grandmother realized like you you invest
in great american companies
and you just keep investing and you
leave it and you leave it and you leave
it and she helped me buy my first stock
at age seven at mcdonald's wow and that
was seven years old it was like she
taught me
she taught me three lessons about money
at seven that to this day i still teach
which i can share with you what's that
so
at seven we're sitting at mcdonald's
and she says you know david you can get
rich at mcdonald's i looked around my
grandma i'm eating my you know my
cheeseburger and my french fries and i
have my apple pie
i said what are you talking about and
she's like
i'm not getting a job here she's like
see those people over there they're
working for what's called minimum wage
and i think back then minimum wage was
like a dollar nothing and she said it's
very hard to make a living on minimum
wage
she said then there's people like you
right now like all these people
are coming here and they're eating and
they're spending money
that's called a spender and she said
then there's some people who own this
place
and owners get rich and she said and i
love to play monopoly at seven that was
my thing i go to my grandmother and she
played monopoly with me and she said i'm
gonna teach you how to play monopoly for
real and she took me home that day she
opened up the wall street journal she
circled mcd that's the symbol still to
this day for mcdonald's
and she said here's how much mcdonald's
is she put me in front of a television
screen and said watch ticker tape she
taught me how to read that ticker tape
and she said just call out the price on
mcd that's the price of mcdonald's and
she said tomorrow i'll take you down our
broker's firm will open up an account
and you'll you'll buy one share of that
stock
and then every time you go there you'll
know you're making money from yourself
wow
that is a wow right and it's funny
because i'm here in la with you but i
just went to disneyland two days ago
with my son my son who's nine
and disneyland did you buy disney i
bought disney that was my sec that was
my second stock that's amazing so like
literally at nine i'm at disney with
grandma and i'm like hey mickey are you
guys public like you know cause she
taught me to think
as a child
like an investor
now i'm doing the same thing with my
kids now my kids don't want to own
mcdonald's they want to own shake shack
right so my son owns shake shack right
down the street
my younger son after disneyland was like
i want to own disney his older brother
owns disney it's doubled he's like well
i want to own disney my kids own amazon
so you know they're they're learning
like i learned
now this stuff should be taught in
school today this is the school right
like today what we do is another way to
teach people
so
but those are simple lessons i just gave
you
that were passed to me and we just did
that in a matter of minutes rule number
five invest in yourself with dean
graziosi i remember hearing a story
where this couple
wanted their whole life their dream
their desire their whole life was to
move to the west coast and get a house
on the ocean well they saved up their
whole life pushing their their they were
delaying their happiness delaying their
gratification until they got this house
they get this house they move in it's
paradise it's heaven the first month
every night they're watching the sun go
down watching the sun sets having a
glass of wine toasting baby we made it
fast forward six months this is a true
story at least the person who told me
the story said it was a true story um
six months later the wife was like honey
we have to get blinds put on the west
facing windows it's so annoying every
night when i'm cooking the damn sun is
coming through the windows and it's so
hard to pay attention
wow
their whole life to watch the sunsets
over the ocean became annoying
so we have to watch what we're spending
money on and make sure is that feeding
some significance that we're trying to
prove to someone else we're trying to
prove that we made it we're starting
show off the rolex show off the
lamborghini
listen i think everyone if you need to
go through that phase but here's the
same thing i tell my kids and i want to
tell
you figure out what success means to you
on the deepest level possible i went
through the fantasy watch phase of my
life i have hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of watches i don't wear
any right now not that i'd criticize
anyone who does i wear t-shirts all the
time now i have thousand dollar sports
jackets because i went through that
phase but what i'm realizing and i'm
realizing a little bit later in life
that's why i want to get to everybody no
matter what age you are is that the
moments in between
are what where the magic lives so i
asked you what you were spending money
on i want you to make sure you're
investing enough money into you into
your personal growth into the business
you have or into the business you want
to create or into growing yourself so
you could be an entrepreneur if that's
the right word like grow within your
company i don't care where you want to
grow but you need to grow and i want to
make sure you're spending money on
things that give you an roi either an
roi on wisdom an roi and success an roi
on memories roi on happiness and roi on
health so i'm thinking i i mean i what i
was thinking even in my own life and i
want to share with you is you need to
create an audit of where your money is
being spent because here's what i know
i'm so far from cheap i i don't stress
about money i didn't stress about money
spending it for other people especially
when i didn't have any when i was paying
on credit cards to help other people out
i i always had this feeling i know i can
create more now do i worry about it of
course or i have in the past but i
always knew i could create more money
but when i look back i realized how much
money got spent on things that mean
nothing
and now i spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars on my own education i go to at
least 10 to 12 masterminds every single
year and every time i go oh my god i'll
gain capabilities on how to go faster on
facebook or write a book quicker or how
to market better or how to invest in new
real estate in new industries or i'll
get a tip from a guy who's an amazing
dad or a mom who's in a great
relationship and blow my mind like i
came here to make more money but i got a
tip on how to bond with my daughter
better father daughter bonding this
guy's amazing boom like exponential
growth through learning from other
people rule number six protect your
income with patrick bay david so reports
just came in that 3.28 million americans
just applied for unemployment this is
not something we're accustomed to this
is not a number we're used to having
this kind of unemployment but at the
same time i was having a conversation
with a few different guys saying pat how
do you protect yourself against a loss
like this i mean you're in the insurance
business you're in the anticipation
business what are you doing something
like this what's the best kind of
insurance for some like this it isn't
life it is an auto insurance it isn't
you know homeowners insurance it isn't
cell phone insurance it isn't any of
that stuff although that stuff has got a
place for it the most important thing
today for a time like this is income
protection insurance and income
protection insurance is based on a few
things that you need to do so let me set
that part aside let me give you a
completely different side that we have
to look at look
2001 911 happens 2008 market crashes
2020 we have the pandemic 2001 and 2020
have a lot in common because they're
both a black swan nobody could have
predicted it 2008 a lot of experts could
have predicted it that's why big short
movie came out
so what would you do with a time like
this there's three different types of
people today the first group are those
that are relying on the stimulus to come
i can't wait for my unemployment and the
thousand dollar check and the 600 a week
for 39 weeks that's awesome i can't wait
for this i'm going to stay home i'm
going to catch up on movies i'm going to
do all this other stuff they're just so
glad that the government's bailing them
out the second group is the one that's
like listen i don't need government's
help i'm okay i've saved money i i
already experienced it 1701 i didn't
want to experience it again i already
went through 108 when i lost a lot of
money to real i told myself that will
never happen to me again i don't need
the government's payload i'm going to be
okay i've saved money i've been
preparing for this time i'm going to be
fine then there's a third group of
people that are saying
i am being forced to change and pat i
can't stand it
i don't like where i'm at right now and
the reality of it is we change in two
different ways one is by choice one is
by force many people today are being
forced to change so those of you
that are in the third group where you're
saying i kind of want to make sure this
never happens to me ever again what do i
do let me kind of give you a few things
to be thinking about number one
these are the time when you realize the
skill set of pivoting and adjusting
whoever knows how to pivot and adjust
they have an edge over everybody else
just know most people are going to watch
what everybody else is going to be doing
a few people are going to be pivoting
adjusting pivoting adjusting with
current times because again we've never
been through this before to pivot and
adjust that's one skill set it's a
mindset you got to learn what to do the
other part
well economically to talk about the
income protection is
knowing what kind of skills pay today
for instance if you don't know how to
zoom you got to learn how to zoom if you
don't know how to do webinars you need
to learn how to do webinars if you're
not a person that facetimes a lot you
need to learn how to do facetime if
you're not somebody on facebook or
social media or instagram that goes live
you need to learn how to do that if
you're not a social media person you
need to learn how to do that if you
don't create content you may need to
learn how to do that if you don't have a
service to sell that's not a physical
product today maybe you need to learn
how to sell a service today if you're
not a good salesperson maybe you need to
learn how to sell today because those
skill sets are required today so when
this happens
the income protection the insurance
policy for your income protection is
knowing that you know how to make money
when everything is fine but you also
know how to make money when the economic
growth of 128 months in a row expansion
stops you also know how to make money in
times like this and rule number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is develop money eq with ken
honda what i found out is that people
want to learn about money iq which is
about financial intelligence it's about
investing how to buy stocks and how to
trade and all the other things but what
i found out is that money eq is more
important than money iq money eq is
emotional intelligence about money how
healthy you feel with money a healthy
relationship is that when you feel happy
about money
your money eq is high when you
constantly worry about money and
you you have fear on money but your
money eq is low
and the highest money iq people with all
the mbas and all the doctor degree
they
are good at investing and they're super
good with business but these high money
iq people often lose everything because
of low money eq even though you build a
high tower with money iq the foundation
is shaky it's going to fall
so money eq is a foundation of life for
example if you get a 500 raise which is
great but can you keep the money
probably
you will celebrate your raise and spend
it all and then if you get a 2 000
raise which is great probably you're
gonna move to a better and bigger house
and then you're going to probably buy a
bigger car and more expenses go up so
even though you get a raise you make
more money your expenses also are trying
to match your income so you have no
money at the end of the month anyway i
have known many ceos who are making a
few hundred thousand dollars a year but
still they cannot keep any money left
because their lifestyle consumes all the
money so unless you learn about money eq
and how the solid foundation
you'll never be able to feel peace with
money and you'll never be able to
achieve true financial independence
entrepreneurship is one of the hardest
things that you're ever going to do in
your life
and it's totally worth it
it's totally worth it whether it
actually works out or not most
entrepreneurs will fail something like
85 percent of businesses fail in the
first five years most businesses won't
work but it's totally worth it why
because
you're showing yourself that you bet on
yourself you're showing yourself that
you're following through and taking
action on your ideas that you're worthy
you're showing yourself that you're
worthy
you're showing yourself that you believe
in you
and if you keep doing that
you're gonna win
the path to living a happy life a
fulfilled life
a life that you're proud of
is one where you continue to show up for
yourself
and the minute that you stop when you
stop showing up for yourself when you
just throw in the towel and say this is
over i'm just gonna work for somebody
else i'm gonna help somebody else build
their dreams instead of chasing down
mine
that's when life starts to fall apart
you know that's the path down
to unhappiness and depression and it
doesn't mean that everybody has to be an
entrepreneur
but what you have to do is continue to
bet on yourself you have to continue to
bet on your ideas you have to continue
to say i came up with this good idea
and because i came up with it therefore
it's a worthy endeavor for me to chase
it
down i got asked on my live stream
yesterday how do i know when to quit you
know it is quitting is quitting bad
do i quit on something how do i know
when to quit
some people say never give up never give
up always keep going and some people
are the opposites what's the right
advice
the right answer is if you love it you
have to keep going
if you love it you have you have to find
a way to keep going
so for a lot of cases
that's what entrepreneurship is you've
got a dream you've got a mission you've
got some goals that that you generally
love that you really want to
to build to create to serve to help
people with
and it's that love that's going to keep
you going because in the early days it's
going to suck it's the it's the
chewing glass and eating to the abyss
right you have that moment of high at
the beginning of i'm going to start this
thing oh my god it's so exciting and
then you you land into the valley of no
momentum nothing working not no results
nobody praising you anymore nobody's
celebrating you for starting the
business
now you're in the actual running of it
and you're not getting the results that
you want and you're trying to
show how you're winning and post it on
instagram and you're but you're not and
you know you're not and you feel like a
fraud
and this is this is the life cycle that
a lot of entrepreneurs go through
but if you love it
you have to keep going you have to you
have to you have to
you could be a lot more honest you could
be a lot more vulnerable you could be a
lot more authentic
you can understand that you have you
don't have to do this all by yourself
this is my biggest problem when i
started my company i was i was failing i
was flat out failing i was 300 bucks a
month like
failing
and i was too embarrassed and ashamed to
tell my friends that i was feeling i
wanted to look like
i was doing well because i turned down
the jobs that they all went and got and
they're all making
high five figure low six figure jobs at
a university and i'm
making
300 bucks a month i was just embarrassed
i was just too embarrassed and i made it
harder on myself
to be alone
you don't have to be alone you can make
it easier by just letting people in
when you're down in the dumps being by
yourself is usually the worst thing
if you can be around other people
especially people who support you
a lot of people will
let's circle back to
the idea that if you don't love it
you're going to regret it why why do you
have to keep going
why do you have to keep going why is it
so important if you love it because you
will regret it
because you will look back on this
moment in your life and say i should
have
done more i could have done more i
regret not giving it one more week one
more month
one more year i regret it you will
regret it that's the only thing that
saved my first business
i quit on my partner i told him i'm done
i need to feel like i'm a valuable human
again nothing i'm doing is working and i
hate how this makes me feel as a person
nothing against
you or the business just how i feel i
need to feel like i'm valuable again
somehow
that was the conversation and then the
next day woke up and i said i can't quit
because i'm going to regret this i know
i'm going to regret this i'm gonna be
an old man at 40.
i'm 41 now i'm getting an old man at 40
and regret that i wasted my life and i
didn't do this thing
and that's the only thing that gave me
the the courage
the motivation the energy to get back up
and just keep going you will regret this
if you love it and you stop now you will
regret this for your entire life
now on the flip side i think there are
many things that you should quit on
sooner
the the difference is if you don't love
it you need to quit on it if you don't
love it anymore and maybe you never
loved it in the first place then you
need to move on because you will never
win doing work that you hate
the people who are at the top of their
game people that i've i've studied how
many successful people have i studied
and profiled and showcased on on all of
these channels how many so many people
right the one thing they all have in
common is that they love what they do
they love the process they love the work
they love the grind it's not a grind for
them because they're in it so much and
they love it
so that's who you're going up against
right and if you don't love it you're
always gonna lose no matter how smart
you are you're going to lose because
you're going up against people who
absolutely love the thing
and so that's what you need you need to
be loving your thing and so if you're in
it just as a strategy
you're going to lose move on immediately
as soon as your heart's not into it
either sell it or if it's too new then
then you just flat out move on i think
people saying relationships are too long
i think people stay in businesses for
too long because you're afraid of
failure because you're afraid of what it
means if you quit on something and go to
something else you're afraid of what
people are going to say you're afraid of
what the person looking back at you in
the mirror is going to think if you quit
you're afraid of the uncertainty of
where to go next because if this thing
at least i know what this thing is doing
i don't know what the future holds to me
if i go somewhere else
a lot of people are handcuffed by having
a little bit of money not not a lot but
enough to survive and that then
prevents them from taking the next jump
which they actually need to do because
their hearts aren't in the thing
so many people start a business because
they're just trying to make money
people ask me what's what's the number
one
business to get into for this year to
make a lot of money that's the wrong
question you're asking that question
you're going to lose you can't start
with how to make money you start with
the thing that you love that brings
value and inside of that you're making
money making money is important a
hundred percent if you don't make money
you will not have a business making
money has to be in your top five of
priorities but if you make it number one
you're gonna lose because you're always
gonna be chased in the next hot thing
never get good enough at anything to
actually be the best in the world which
is actually how you start to make a lot
of money you need to be the best in the
world at something how do you get that
by loving the things so much
and by wanting to serve and help people
get better at it too
that's how you win what problems out
there can feasibly be fixed say in our
lifetimes
well i mean i think first of all
um
the world's actually pretty great right
now i mean arguably better than any
point in history
and this this is sometimes uh lost if
you read the
newspapers they're
they're like
a magnification of all
the world's promises like
newspapers seem to be attempting to
answer the question what was the worst
thing that happened on earth today
[Applause]
yeah it's
if it bleeds it leads yeah and and it's
like okay i mean and i think there's
there is kind of a evolutionary reason
for that because it makes more sense to
like you want to
prioritize danger over reward or or
because
it's
if you get eaten by the lion it's game
over but
you know if if you forget where you left
some snack that's that's okay i mean you
you know so
so there's a
it's it's
not quite the same in terms of the
restaurant balance but
we didn't evolve with newspapers uh and
and and global media so like our brains
sort of having a fear response to a lot
a bunch of dangers that are extremely
unlikely to ever affect us how do you
get to where you're at how do you think
the way you think how can you
self-actualize how can you be positive
um
do you have
can you identify a reason well for me
it's a little easier than maybe for some
people because one when you're down and
out more than once you don't know money
no nothing and something good happens oh
boy this is great but i was with all due
respect i was born i think positive i i
my mom would always tell me my god be
careful mom i'm gonna be just fine i was
kind of think boring positive you know
then obviously when you're down you go
up you get even more positive because
you're so happy and then when you have
an abundance of something and you get to
share it with people and you see a good
end result it's just it's happy if you
ever you do something for somebody else
and ask absolutely nothing in return
it's the greatest high you'll ever get
now i went through the 60s okay it's the
greatest high you'll ever get when you
help somebody say that and you ask
nothing in return yes absolutely nothing
in return it's higher than smoking
anything is that what you how you would
describe a good giver
yeah when you give to somebody or
something or some environment whether
it's the environment for the planet or
for people
and you ask nothing in return you do it
because it's the thing to do
oh you get a good high everyone likes
being knowledge but do it sometime and
don't tell anybody you did it like
there'll be times austin especially i'll
go downtown and when i'm in l.a i'll do
it because i was homeless here once and
i'll hand out hundred dollar bills i'll
just go back to this for you
and i just keep on walking and one lady
they gave a stack to it was a ten
thousand dollar stack she was just the
kind of sweetest lady and i talked to
her a little bit she told me a little
about her life and i said i give you a
couple dogs oh no no i found out a way
to make it okay because i don't like to
ask for anything they said okay so i
just held her hand and i said can i put
a note in your pocket sure so i just put
the note in the pocket i realized this
built ten thousand output in her pocket
there was folded with a rubber band i
said you are so blessed
once you wait a few minutes before
reading my note say a little prayer then
read the note okay and i disappeared
what does max out really stand for for
you and when did that moment happen
where you knew that that was gonna be
part of your brand yeah um
my son's name's max so that helped um
but maxed out to me means this as you
know um your obsessions become your
possessions whatever you end up being
obsessed with you'll eventually possess
so if you're obsessed with what you're
worried about your fears your problems
you're going to possess those
and so
i became obsessed
the the short version is is that you
don't know this i don't talk about this
on camera very much when i was 30 my
uncle died at 50 years old
and he was the guy in my family we all
have this that you kind of resemble or
remind everybody else
my dad's brother he died at 50. sorry no
thank you i appreciate that it's a long
time ago now and um but he was kind of
with my godfather and my culture that's
a big deal of course might as well yeah
i know shout out uncle mike yeah mine
was uncle mike
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa it's got chills
everywhere right there whoa whoa whoa
whoa
whoa
whoa
that's how the universe works right
wow okay
you got me right there
so mine was my uncle mike
wow
and
no man i just touched me
so
mine was my uncle mike and uh that blows
my mind right there brother
so
i'm on i'm at his funeral
we're flying back on the flight there's
this thing in your brain called the
reticular activating system it basically
filters into your awareness what's
important to you that's why like if you
buy a new car all of a sudden you see
that car everywhere on the freeway three
lanes over on the other side boom
another one they were always there why
do you see them now it's filtered into
your importance
and heart attacks were at my he died of
a heart attack and so i'm on the
airplane and i'm listening to music and
on the screens the oprah show but i'm
it's in my awareness and it's a heart on
the screen i'm like
unplug my headphones plug it into the
phone system and it was about a new
heart scan that was happening at
cedars-sinai where they could like it's
common now but they could not evasively
look at your heart and your arteries
long story short
i hear it and i told my wife i said
schedule me for one of those exams she's
like it's expensive i don't care
schedule it we call it's a nine month
wait i go i need to get in i need to get
in i keep calling the lady finally she
goes there's a cancellation tomorrow at
two i go i'll be there so i go down for
the scan and thank god this doctor
understood influence and leverage do you
do the scan then you come back after
lunch i literally went ate a burrito
came back i wasn't in shape i'm 30 years
old the doctor comes out and he goes um
i'm no i'm looking for edward milot i go
it's my let you know and he goes uh he
knew he goes
whoa i can't believe these arteries are
in that young body wow you need to come
back son
now my
heart's racing i'm like what the hell's
in the skin we sit down instead of what
a normal doctor would do they just go
hey um uh here's the prescription take
crest store out eat goodbye
he understood reasons is what changes
people's lives massive reasons not
discipline reasons and habits right
because let me ask you a question your
wife's beautiful
um
do you have kids i go yeah i go i got a
son he's one he goes that's great um do
you want to be there when he graduates
high school
i went what he goes do you want to be
there when he graduates high school i
said uh yeah he goes
okay uh is she pregnant huh i go yeah
what does she have and i said a girl you
get to a dad this is what you say he
goes would you like to walk that little
girl down the aisle on her wedding day
son
i went what
what is in this scan dude and he goes i
want to be very clear with you young man
i remember this like yesterday because i
want to be very clear with you young man
if you continue down the road you're
going another man's gonna live with your
beautiful wife in your mansion
walk your son at graduation and he's
gonna be arm in arm with your daughter
on her wedding day not you you'll be
long gone
actually as i tell you this right now
dude right
and he goes what i'm gonna get you to do
is i'm gonna get you to max out your
life and your fitness
and i went
give me it
yeah and he gave me exactly what i
needed to do and he said if you do this
you'll walk her down the aisle blah blah
blah from that day
when i get up like i did this morning
and i'm tired and i was late last night
and i don't want to go to the gym i
swear to you brother i swear to you i go
bella's wedding get your ass up
and i go i i'm fit because i have
massive reasons that's why i'm fit and
that started the journey towards maxing
out every area of my life i'm like i can
do this in my fitness i can do this in
business i can do this in my
spirituality and everything i'm not
gonna shortchange myself by pretty good
i'm gonna see what my real potential is
what my maximum capacity is every single
day because at the end of my life when i
do die i have this belief that when i'm
done the lord's gonna go well done good
and faithful servant and by the way
here's the man you could have been
this is the man you were born to be this
is the man you were destined to be this
is where you could have gone but you
could have seen the memories you could
have had the people you could help the
person you could have become and meet
him my obsession is that every day i'm
chasing that dude so that when i do die
we meet we're identical twins because
the bad end of a life whether it would
be at 30 50 or 150 would be i meet that
guy and we're total strangers so i'm
obsessed with meeting that guy someday
and that's what maxing out means you
know now i'm going through and teaching
myself neural networks and you know
doing the same thing with machine
learning and gans and this and that
because
ai
is going to have more of an impact than
the internet did ai plus new types of
chipsets plus 5g is going to change
things far more than we've ever seen
anything change and understanding where
and how to apply it is going to be
critical but just as important knowing
how to sep
segregate and separate them
right is as important because every
email you are about to send me
is going to say i have this ai solution
and we're using algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if i
didn't do that work if i didn't sit down
and do the aws machine learning
tutorials if i didn't go on youtube and
take you know the nyu introduction to
neural networks or whatever i'm not
going to know it i'm not going to be
able to apply it and i'm not going to be
able to be first and that's fun
that's fun knowing i get to kick the ass
to some 22 year old nyu graduate that's
awesome you know what's the best advice
that you've received someone told me
that what you delegate is 80
as good as you would have done it
yourself let it go oh wow i took
inventory of what am i good at what am i
not good at what do i you know enjoy and
don't enjoy and they're usually the same
thing ironically like i was very clear
in the first year i was not good at
shipping and handling and i wasn't good
at you know
so many different things about managing
the inventory but i loved inventing the
next idea i loved the brand i loved the
way that i was communicating with
consumers so being able to free yourself
up to do what you do best
and let the people who do the other
aspects do us do it i've made myself you
know understand uh i.t information
technology and if you talk to any ceo of
any company they'll tell you that's the
one department that you do not want to
because no matter who you bring in
everybody has their own way of doing it
and and i've just still made myself uh
understand technology even though i'm
not a millennial i try to at least know
a little bit about every single
department even if i don't know it a lot
and so walk me through you want to learn
about i.t what do you do you googling it
or do you go sit down with the head of
i.t and say teach me everything no i
just i i want to i want to know
everything i want to understand this you
know you know malware how people are are
getting into all of our systems and
hackiness and
and uh i just process for learning
though just sitting down and say you got
to make me smarter on this you got to
you got to help me through these steps
because i don't get it don't go into too
much minutia because you'll lose me
because i'm not that smart but you got
to give me the steps of why this is
happening or not happening and that's
something that everybody should do you
don't have to understand you know that
i'm going to go and be able to program
something or or write something but but
we should all if we're running a company
understand some portion of it uh when
i'm shooting billion dollar buyer i know
what all these different people do and
exactly what they're doing and how
important you know each person is and
and uh it's just trying to understand
what you do and it makes you appreciate
that person and how smart they are at
that job too and how important they are
to your company you know if if you're
see self improvements not even just with
cars with your own body you know when
you go work out
do you feel better when you come out of
a gym all pumped up or you feel better
when you haven't worked out for a month
yeah of course you know you're when you
go to gym you know you're building your
you know something happens when you see
changes in your body with your assets
when you see even
gaining a good friend i have my down
days you know i'm sure you do too we're
all human you know you could have all
the money in the world you're still
going to have a bad day you know
absolutely you don't know what's going
to cause it but you know you do and you
know for me working out is great i have
a personal trainer three times a week
and then when i don't have my personal
trainer i just get out of bed and drop
on the floor and do 20 push-ups 30
push-ups i do it until i can't do it
anymore and then i hit the shower and i
feel great you know and it's you know
it's just
keeping
the fluids going you know your mind
fresh yeah because workout not just
improves your physics it also helps your
mind a greed and
sometimes it helps your mentality more
than your physique but people don't
realize it you know it helps you focus i
write down my day
and what i do is i go back and study
that day like sometimes i might i might
get sick i might be over trained i might
um
gain a couple pounds here i might feel
whatever
that and i it's like my accountability
journal
of what i'm doing with my life physical
mental um
i had an eating journal all that
and helps me go back to once again study
i'm a lab rat
and i study myself
and i'm like when i'm feeling [ __ ] up
i go okay what i do last week
and usually i can find out where i
messed up
last week you know how much i'm
traveling how much i'm sleeping how much
i'm doing all this stuff and
and through journaling man you can
really figure out so much
about where you're messing up in life
and what you need to fix about yourself
taking constant inventory costing honest
about that and that's the thing about
you cannot put in there yeah it's gotta
be a real a real journal about hey today
i messed up here today i should have
been a better person here and not just
saying it but actually trying to fix it
tomorrow you know i find if i'm stressed
about something it's usually because i'm
not doing anything about it and so if
i'm stressed about something i'm trying
to figure out why am i stressed i'm
listening to my body
as a signal
that i'm that something is awry and then
i find that the stress goes away
the second i take the first step of you
know identify the source of the stress
why am i stressed about this what's
going on
and then
you know talk to somebody about it find
you know find allies
um you know i would say that
if you can find
friends
who are interested in similar things or
want to help you solve a problem
problem solving is
is inspiring for me all by itself i have
as long as i have allies there's nothing
more fun than getting in a room
with a group of
inventors and saying look
here's the problem let's invent a
solution to it and as soon as you start
doing that i find that it turns from
something that might create stress into
something that
creates fun i turned it around you know
i
i did my job
in four hours and i was on there there
was a wall that separated production
from the offices and the lunchrooms
because in production there was you know
quality control you couldn't go in there
unless you had hair nets and you know
protective equipment
so what i did is i borrowed some
protective equipment i went in there and
i started hanging out with the operators
the people that were running the lines
and i started taking their trash outside
uh and then uh
if they want this is cool this is the
truth i don't know you know people will
like it but if they wanted a cigarette
break
you know to go outside and smoke you
know this is this is 70 right you know
everybody smokes uh so i would say well
just show me what to do you know you
just be gone for five minutes and
they're like uh i don't know right now
come on just i'm i'm a mechanic you know
and i really am you know and uh so they
would teach me you know uh how to watch
the line and they would go outside
you know and i'd do that for a couple of
weeks and so so the other managers were
telling my manager like hey uh
the guy on your crew that mops in the
night man hey uh i just want to thank
you for letting him take my trash out my
guys helped him and they were like what
who did that
you know and he was like
like okay he was like no one had ever
done that
you know you heard the old statement
that's not my job
but after he told after he told me that
i i never said i said i'm employed here
that is my job
you know
that is my job and
and little by little i learned how to
run the the dorito lines
you know how to and it is it is like
being a pilot it's not you know people
say you just make chips oh no no man
it's like you got to go to pilot school
to learn how to make
doritos and potato chips and freedom
believe me it takes a couple years to be
a master do it anyway
is a mindset trick that you can use when
you start to feel excuses rolling up it
works a lot like the five-second rule so
you
have said to yourself okay i'm gonna
talk to my boss today
about that thing that i've been avoiding
talking to them about
or maybe you've said something like i'm
gonna go to the gym today or tomorrow or
whatever and then the moment comes where
you've got to have that conversation
or the moment comes where it's time to
pack up your bag and leave your desk and
go to the gym
and what always happens
you don't feel like it
i bet there are plenty of you watching
that have made a commitment that i'm not
going to have a drink tonight and then
guess what happens when you get home
you don't feel like not drinking you
feel like having a drink and so here's
what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that i just do it anyway
has pushed me to realize and to
recognize that there are a lot of
moments where there are things in my
life that i really want to do
i need to do
i should do
but when the moment comes
i don't feel like it
and so i pull out this idea of you know
what i'm just gonna do it anyway
it's raining outside i said i would go
for a short run i don't feel like it i'm
gonna do it anyway it's six o'clock in
the morning i'm tired
it's cold
i laid out my yoga clothes but now i
don't feel like it what do i do i do it
anyway when you start to say to yourself
i'm gonna do it anyway what happens is
something really cool you acknowledge
that there are feelings that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you
you acknowledge them and you basically
say guess what
i'm gonna do it anyway on an individual
level i think it is always uh it's
always really good if if there's
something that you're incredibly
passionate about and um and just sort of
are fine to be intrinsically interesting
and and that that people pursue that um
and so the you know one of the
one of the the resolutions i came up
with a number of years ago was to always
uh
value substance over status substance
over prestige um
and you know if i sort of was giving my
younger self advice on what to what to
do or how to how to think about um your
when's one's life
i you know i probably i think i you know
um i probably still go to stanford um
you know i i might still go to law
school um but i'd ask i'd ask sort of
i'd ask a lot more questions why i was
doing these things and i think
i think if i was honest about it
too much of it was driven by
by prestige and status and not quite
enough about um really the substance of
uh of trying to learn things and you
know i had sort of this i sort of think
of it as this sort of crazy rolling
quarter life crisis and sort of
culminated in this uh in this you know
big new york law firm where you know
from the outside everybody wanted to get
in from the inside everybody wanted to
get out um you know um after i lasted
seven months and three days and after uh
um and when i when i when i left one of
the people down the hall said you know
it's so reassuring to see you leave
peter i had no idea it was possible to
escape from alcatraz which which again
uh and you know and again i and all you
had to do was go through the front door
but our identity um people's identities
get so wrapped up and um the things they
compete for that it was inconceivable
for people to actually do that and and
then the question was you know well how
had i ended up there why had i not
thought about that more and i think it
was um that i had taken too many of
these shortcuts of valuing sort of what
was prestigious what was conventional
over what i uh what i really wanted to
do so i think i think always substance
over status when you first launched in
the very beginning the features were
sort of profiled with like a profile
photo and your name and who you are and
also you included things like what house
you lived in um what dorm you lived in
um and what courses you were taking
do you think it would have worked
without that would it have been enough
just to have profiles
you know it's a really interesting
question and we certainly since then
have evolved and wanted to make a more
general service so we've so we've
dropped some of those things
but i remember um there's this early
debate that dustin and i had where
we had to do some manual work for every
school that we that we released facebook
at and um in order to do that we
basically went through and we parsed the
course catalogs of the schools to make
sure that the data was clean
and um and i remember having this debate
where dustin was like we could just
expand so much faster
or it would just be easier i mean we
were bound by server capacity but it
would be easier to launch new schools
if we didn't have to have course
catalogs for each school and we just had
this really long debate
about what quality meant for us and the
the community that we wanted to
establish and and the culture of it and
um you know in retrospect you know maybe
it wouldn't have had a huge difference
on on how things played out but it
definitely kind of set this tone where
there's a lot of kind of clean data on
facebook you can rely on it it feels
like a college specific thing
which was valuable early on for setting
the culture even though obviously since
then we've grown beyond that and you
know i mean i think you guys in the
projects that you work on you're gonna
have a lot of similar questions right i
mean there's the famous 80 20 rule where
you know you get 80 percent of the
benefit by doing 20 of the work uh but
you can't just 80 20 everything right i
mean there have to be certain things
that you just are the best at right and
that you go way further than anyone else
had to establish this kind of quality
bar and have your product be the best
thing that's out there so you know
whether we had to do that one or had to
do something we had to do i think enough
of those things or else we just wouldn't
have been the best service out there you
know i think that uh i think there
definitely are things that one can
iterate on but the the core thing is to
have a great product and then you can
always improve and and iterate on that
in all sorts of ways and i think you
know i think even in the tech industry
um
what's striking is how
um
weak on a quantitative basis so many of
the successful companies were it was
just they had a great product and then
years later they were able to optimize
it and all sorts of
all sorts of ways
whereas if you're just trying to
optimize and you don't have a great
product
i think that that rarely works um i
think it's always worth asking you know
where you're going to go with this
business um and so i think we're always
focused on very short time horizons
because you have to you know figure out
a way to get through the next month the
next quarter um you know how do you get
some customers how do you how do you
track but it's it's always worth
thinking ahead you know five to ten
years you know why will this be a really
valuable business in five to ten years
and um you know how's the competitive
landscape going to develop how is
technology going to develop how's the
world going to develop um these are hard
questions to answer but i think um i
think i think i think the the great
entrepreneurs that i know always have
some perspective on it and it might be
wrong but it's just this is what's going
to happen and then it's sort of well
reasoned and and so you have a you have
a plan it and you know it's when i when
i was playing chess uh you know in
junior high school one of the early
lessons i learned was a bad plan is
still always better than no plan at all
right and so
you know have a plan you can always
change it but don't don't just pretend
that uh that you have no clue about
what's going to happen and that
everything about the future is random if
you if you sort of say that everything's
random and out of your control that's
that's that's the way you set yourself
up for failure i think you should be
doing something you're passionate about
so the question is always
you know when i give my younger self
advice you know if would i still go to
stanford and this will go to stanford
law school
um possibly but i think a lot more about
why i was doing it was it is it just uh
you know and i was on this super tract
myself i ended up at a big law firm in
new york uh in my eighth grade junior
high school yearbook one of my friends
wrote and i know you're gonna get into
stanford in four years i went to
stanford four years later went to
stanford law school ended up at a big
law firm in uh in new york where on the
outside everybody wanted to get in on
the inside everybody wanted to get out
um
when i left after uh seven months and
three days
um
one of the one of the people down the
hall from me said it was you know really
reassuring to see that it was possible
to escape from alcatraz which you know
all you had to do was really just go out
the front door but um but so much of um
our identity gets wrapped up in the
competitions we win
and um that um and when you when you
compete
um and i think a lot of the
credentialing resume building is this
sort of competition when you compete you
do get better at what you're competing
at if you take lots of sat test prep
classes you'll get a better score on the
sat um and when you compete you get
better at beating people on the narrow
things you need to beat them on but um
but you often it often comes at this
very high price of of losing sight of
what's uh what's truly valuable and
important and meaningful
which is
well i think passion there's well
there's sort of all sorts of other
there's all sorts of things that that
could be that but but i think
um i think it often the the i think it
often ends up being
uh something that's a little bit off the
beaten path because uh so i think um you
know there's there's obviously financial
version where you get to be have a
monopoly like business
there's a the meaningful version i think
is always counterfactual where if you
weren't doing this
uh would you know it's great to be
working on problems where if you weren't
working on them nobody else would do
them you know if you're working at the
fourth online pet food company the 10th
in film solar panel company the 1000th
restaurant in philadelphia
there's a sense that if you weren't
doing it someone else would
um you know if you're working at uh
at something where
it's the only thing of its kind in the
world that's very meaningful if we
weren't if we and it could be for-profit
non-profit all sorts of context if we
weren't doing this this problem would
absolutely not be tackled i think that's
the kind of
that's what's that's what's meaningful
the thing i think that i did right from
the beginning
and even
now in this moment uh now that my
circumstances are very different is i've
i've always known
and this comes from i think my faith
deep down inside i've always known that
like what i'm called to do isn't about
me
and so
for me it's it's what's fueled me
in all the times
when it seemed like no one else believed
in me like i knew why i was doing this
um was so much bigger than myself and to
really shift culture and beauty and even
now
even just saying like oh my gosh
you started something in your living
room and someone pays you a billion
dollars for it like if i think about
that i can't even process it right i
can't even handle it because what
happens is i'll start thinking of like
oh but you know
i don't i didn't come from the right
family no one of my neither my parents
went to college all those things that we
tell ourselves about why
we're not the person that has those kind
of things happening to us
um
and so so two things one i i often
remind myself that like anything that's
ever been created that's great or that's
a brand we all use now or a big business
like it was all created by somebody
really at the end of the day who's just
like you and me just like all of us
every single thing right so like why not
i'm not you why not yeah and then and
then the other thing is like when i
really start to um
kind of like get in my own head about it
because it is really
strange you see like oh yeah like
all those things like um
i i make it not about my i know i remind
myself it's it's not about me right so
for my book for example i'm donating 100
of the proceeds but like like i the the
book is to serve right and like i i
believe at the end of the day that we
get in life like what we give you know
what i mean along this whole journey
i've known it's bigger than myself even
now like i just i don't know i believe
that you know i'm called to serve and
and to
like i feel blessed to have accomplished
one of my biggest dreams but my my
biggest
my biggest driver now is helping other
women um
and especially their entrepreneurs and
really other women like accomplish their
greatest dreams i know that one of the
key things one of the things that's made
me successful in my life
is making it a priority to control
my thoughts like what what am i thinking
about like literally putting discipline
in on
how i talk to myself
and so i don't want this to sound all
cycle babble stuff it's not like it's
not like oh if you just stand in the
mirror and talk to yourself and say
positive things everything's gonna be
all right be careful what you say to
yourself okay
because if you're saying a thirty dollar
stake is a lot of money
or a four dollar toy is a lot of money
when your kid wants a four dollar toy
listen to what you're saying
that's a lot of money
dude four dollars is a lot of money okay
on my worst day four dollars has not
been a lot of money even though
okay i've been at periods in my life
where i didn't have four dollars
so i'm talking to you today about
how do you control
how do you control
how do you discipline
how do you start monitoring what you're
saying to yourself
i can't find the right girl
can't find the right guy there's no good
guys left in this town all men are pigs
women cheat on their men
marriage is hard
having kids is difficult
i don't want to pay taxes
you know
i can't help myself i can't stop
i can't trust myself i never do what i
say i procrastinate i'm an introvert
i'm broke i'm poor
so
look what are you saying to yourself all
the time the first thing i did was i
took a i took a little journal out and i
just wrote down all the negative things
i say to myself by the way i just gave
you the list
okay
i can't spend money
i can't save enough money i don't make
enough money okay i don't know how to
invest in the stock market i can't
invest in real estate i don't have time
to do this you know the time thing
people just kill themselves with the
time thing i don't have enough time i
don't have enough time i don't have
enough time guess what
oops
you don't have enough time you don't
have time you don't have money catch
yourself every time you say i don't have
time
say hey i create time
every time you say i don't have money
i create money
um or maybe just start just start
literally like talking to yourself that
hey i am a millionaire i am a
multi-millionaire i own
if you want to if you're in the
apartment game and you want to be in
apartments but you don't know anything
about apartments you can start literally
talking to yourself saying i am worth
uh uh or i own 100 units i did this for
years for years before i ever bought an
apartment i used to write down i own 20
apartments that earns 12 percent cash
flow
all right over and over i bet i better
wrote this down a thousand times i own
20 apartments my first deal was 38 units
i own 20 apartments or more
and and i write it in any little journal
any piece of paper any legal path every
time you say something negative write
down
i need to lose weight
okay
that's good but you know if you're
running a race
you don't say i need to finish the race
you're like you're looking for that
you're you got to run right you got to
run you got to move you got to keep
moving your feet so i mean you can sit
there and say i got to finish this race
but the truth is if you need to lose
weight man just once you pick your
target weight
and start affirming
that i weigh 165 pounds i weigh 165
pounds so just switch it a little bit
right all you're trying to do is
discipline you're trying to move the
river so if you're broke right now quit
saying i am broke
and start saying what you want where are
you going there's nothing that ai won't
impact as big as the so
having been around a while i saw the
impact of pcs then i saw the impact of
local area networks then i saw the
impact of wide area networks then i saw
the impact of the internet then i saw
the impact of mobile then i saw the
impact of wireless you know now i'm
seeing the impact of of artificial
intelligence and it dwarfs any of those
things and if i don't understand how to
apply it to my businesses i mean i
remember selling pcs and software and
walking in saying you don't need to use
that pen and paper on on a you know on a
notepad or a ledger pad now we're going
to give you a spreadsheet and by the way
here's a here's a spreadsheet that costs
495 dollars and i had to pay to go get
trained on how to sell it which is crazy
now when you think about it but then we
said okay now you can play what if then
we said you can connect these pcs unless
i understood the technology how was i
going to explain it how was i going to
understand it unless i understand it now
how am i going to invest in it
you know then i got to go trust somebody
who says oh yeah i know ai and maybe
they do maybe they don't and it's really
easy just to have
to okay so you figure it out that's just
not my style so you're building a base
of knowledge and then you think that at
some point it's going to pay dividends
and trust already has right i mean if
they if you truly believe ai is going to
change everything how are you going to
understand what people are doing to
change everything unless you at least
have a foundational understanding of it
now i'm not going to build a million
layer neural network and try to change
the world and i'm not going to show you
i'm not going to write a research paper
and saying here's how why the lottery
ticket approach works and you can build
smaller neural networks with less data
and be more you know
resource efficient but i can read that
stuff and understand that when somebody
says okay we're building this project
and we need this size data set or this
size data set we need this amount of
resources i can ask questions and
understand the answers so how have you
hired your team uh and what do you look
for when you bring people on
if you think about it
you know i started the company when i
was 19 right so
i can't institutionally believe that
experience is that important right or
else i would have a hard time
reconciling um you know myself right and
and and the company so you know we
invest in
in people who we think are just
really talented even if they haven't
done that thing before and you know that
applies to people who are fresh out of
university as well as
you know people like um you know the cfo
who took the company public had not
taken a company public before right and
a lot of his background was in um you
know production
development to genentech before so you
know just focus on really talented
people what is it about selling the that
you actually enjoyed that you think most
people most people don't enjoy selling
so what is it about selling that you
actually well okay this is the first
thing i'm going to say if you don't like
selling
you should really take the time for
yourself to practice it and learn it
because all of life is sales i mean
whether you're an accountant whether
you're a stay-at-home mother and you're
trying to sell your kids on why they
need to go to bed at a certain time or
they need to do something that you need
them to do in an interview you have to
sell yourself i mean and so um i think
it's really important to be able to to
do that and and hardcore door-to-door
sales was incredible groundwork and laid
that laid the foundation for me to be
able to do spanx because when i started
spanx the first two years that i was
cold calling all the manufacturers in
north carolina i only heard one word
no yeah
i mean no no no and because i had
training and just knew i'm gonna keep
going until i get that yes that's the
reason that i was able to get through
that stage
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn how billionaires invest
their money check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there dumbest damn thing you could ever
buy in your life is a big expensive
luxury car if you own the assets and you
don't go into debt
it really becomes a function of time
before you